please discuss voting as a right and
responsibility
vote your conscience what effect does
not voting have
uh vote shaming topic is this next
sentence i'm not sure exactly what that
means love you guys but i like the
the general topic here um
is it both a right and responsibility
well i want to be a little careful
because uh i think there is a way in
which it is irresponsibility
and i wish people took it as one but i
don't necessarily think
um a uninformed vote is such a great
thing so to the extent that voting is
your responsibility you should figure
out
what you should actually be voting for
on the other hand so that
if i may uh it's not that
voting is there is the entirety of the
responsibility if you're going to vote
you should
it should be an informed vote informed
voting should be the responsibility that
you understand yourself to have not
merely voting
yes but i want to put a giant asterisk
on that because
i thought that was the asterisk i want
to put an asterisk
on the asterisk yeah that does sound
like you yeah it does but
um the thing that we all face in our
voter pamphlets is
almost impenetrable and you can't be
informed and who are these judges and
you know um so the point is to the
extent that there is this temptation
to finger wag at people and say oh
you know those uninformed voters the
point is well we set them up for failure
we set ourselves up for failure
and so ideally what you want is a system
that gives you the ability to vote on
that which you have the ability to be
informed
about and delegates where it needs to
delegate to people who can handle the
responsibility and of course
what we have is a giant you know corrupt
entity
that stands in place of all this and it
loves to hand us confusing
garbage and manipulate us into feeling
emotional about it and all the things
that it does
but ideally yes you would want people to
take
you know voting as a privilege and a
responsibility
and to treat it very
seriously now one thing i would say is
there's a longer discussion for another
time about the fact
that if you take all of the people who
don't vote
and you separate them into two groups
there are people who
don't care they're apathetic they're not
paying attention
they don't see themselves as having a
stake yeah and then you take
you separate them from the people who
are frustrated and angry that they never
have something they feel good
about voting for yep right that second
group
is very large and if you compile them
with all of the people who do vote for
one of the major
party candidates
there are enough votes in that group
to transform civilization and the fact
that we are told
well first of all we're fine with you
not voting basically we're going to
give you an awful situation and drive
you out and people are going to feel
good about not voting because they know
that voting is stupid which in some
sense it has become
that this causes a collective
failure of imagination that is the
difference between us
succeeding or continuing to fail in the
same way so at some level
we have to rescue the idea of
protest vote from the concept that it is
a pointless waste of your power because
in fact there's a
ton of power in voting for things other
than the major party candidates
if it registers somewhere the system you
know
doesn't like to count those votes
because it doesn't want there to be
power and
it fears that those who are angry and
disaffected will actually rise up
against the system and insist on
something better
and so what it does is it falsely
convinces us
that we have no power the only thing we
can do is choose between
evils and if we choose to do anything
else that's because we're naive children
who have decided to waste our vote it's
nonsense it's not a waste of a vote it's
a very powerful thing now
personally i think of myself at the
point
you know what do i know i've already
lost this election
i know that my candidate won't win
because my candidate is not
running it's not on the ballot right so
i've already lost this one
does that mean there's nothing to be
done no i'm voting
in the next election right i'm voting in
2020
in the next election by registering the
fact that
i don't accept this lesser evil garbage
i don't know what that means
i'm voting in 2020 in the next election
i don't know what that sentence means
it means that by voting against the
duopoly
one registers that there is a massive
political movement
waiting to be spoken to and
that that signal is power it is not
power to change things in 2020 but it is
power to change things in the future so
if you think about elections you know we
are basically convinced
to think of elections in isolation right
but it is obviously an iterated game and
if this you know if you were to analyze
them if you were an alien coming to
earth to analyze our elections
you wouldn't sit down and think of them
as one-off puzzles you would think of
them as iterated
yep and that affects the game theory so
think of elections as iterated and it
changes what you ought to do no and
that's actually part of the uh
lesser of two evils argument is it
assumes that you're always an end game
yeah it assumes that you're always an
endgame if you don't do it now
everything will end yep absolutely
actually the next question the final
question from episode 48 is related to
that last one
why does being demanded to vote by
celebrities and the media feel like
propaganda
i've always had a strange feeling about
i voted stickers
and comments like if you don't vote you
can't complain
so i feel like we kind of we kind of you
kind of touched on this but
pick up a little bit more well i would i
would add one thing
i do think you should vote so that it is
not ambiguous as to
whether you are apathetic or disaffected
if you are disaffected
you want to register as disaffected and
not
as a non-participant right and the way
to do that
is to vote so it's clear you're willing
to spend the effort and frankly it's not
a huge effort
right but you want to register as
willing to spend the effort
and not up for this [ __ ] right
that's the powerful
move and so you know i do think if you
didn't do that it
makes it ambiguous as to whether or not
you have a right to complain uh to
complain because you might be apathetic
and if you're apathetic or lazy then the
point is actually it does reduce your
right to complain so
i sort of believe it now celebrities
you know unfortunately this is just a
evolutionary it's propaganda
it is propaganda and it's a it's a
novelty problem the fact that
because we are exposed to celebrities
and we recognize them it sort of feels
like they're people in our little town
yeah and they're not yeah right um so
my good friend the person i'll never
meet tells me i need to vote okay